well America is a wonderfully rich
artistic legacy it's predominantly
European even though it's unfashionable
to say that but its a mix of European
cultures that doesn't happen in Europe
and then by the time they got to the
west coast they were suddenly being hit
with with Native American with Asian
with Latin American and oceanic
traditions too and so the American arts
are in a funny way a meeting place of
world culture unto which under kind of a
European DNA everything else has been
grafted perfect example of this is jazz
you know which takes this foursquare
European kind of music and then begins
to syncopate it to African poly rhythms
and you know this you know and if you
look at the way that the after the
african arts largely as they came to the
caribbean into American slave culture
completely transformed what the American
European arts are you know I think that
what we are here is a meeting place a
kind of laboratory of human existence I
mean there's a really interesting thing
and I've never heard anybody say this if
you look at the last hundred years of
the Arts there has never been a place in
all of human history that has had as
much happen as the United States has
during the last hundred years and it's
ranged from classical music to jazz to
rock and roll to hip hop from abstract
expressionist painting to film to comic
books you know to newspaper you know
cartooning novels poetry drama TV etc so
I haven't even begun to exhaust the arts
I mean just music alone and I do believe
that in some funny way this unbelievable
diversity of expression has come out of
the fact that we were the first big
society and history which let the
individual will be free to pursue what
the individual wanted and that's what
you know why it's good not to have a
cultural policy the people should create
their own art in the ways that they want
to do it and so I'm a huge fan of
American Art even though I often
criticized aspects of American culture
there's something happening in American
culture that's never happened before in
all of human history and it's exciting